nous sommes devant le site St
microélectronics leader européen des
circuits intégrés c'est nos emplois qui
sont en jeu dans l'avenir là vous
salarié de cette entreprise vous
citoyens de ce pays devaient dénoncer
cette situation sinon sinon on va au
drame
1500 emplois sont menacés
un choc dans cette entreprise
l'une des plus subventionnées de France
l'État français subventions de fortement
notre entreprise sur 10 ans avec un même
deux milliards il est scandaleux que
soi-même envisagé avec ce niveau
d'intervention et suppression d'emplois
ces dernières années l'État français a
consacré 150 milliards d'euros par an
pour aider les entreprises à se
développer et créer de l'emploi
ces sommes d'argent qui partent dans des
industries ou aujourd'hui on se demande
à quoi elle servent on le voit
aujourd'hui chez Air France on a pu voir
chez les comptines on a pu voir chez
plein dans plein de boutiques où il y a
des problèmes aujourd'hui c'est vraiment
ce scandaleux
prononcer sous le drapeau du Che des
paroles que même le plus libéral de nos
ministres de l'économie et des finances
ne renierait pas
la principale facture de l'assistanat
c'est l'assistana aux entreprises ce
sont les entreprises qui sont assistées
auquel j'ajouterai l'impôt sur le revenu
et sans doute une partie des charges
sociales
aujourd'hui il existe plus de 6000
dispositifs d'État pour aider les
entreprises subventions aide publique
crédit d'impôts des dispositifs
quelquefois détournés
dans ce grand jeu de poker parfois
menteur nous allons nous intéresser à
trois d'entre eux
le vieux le Volontariat International en
Entreprise
le CIR le crédit impôt recherche
et le cice le crédit d'impôt
compétitivité et emploi
derrière ces aides vous allez découvrir
un scandale sur fond d'argent public
l'amorce une pompe à Free qui n'est pas
contrôlée qui n'est pas maîtrisé et on
demande rien à personne des industriels
qui jouent avec le système
de la loi
de tous les pays dans lesquels il se
trouve particulièrement sur paysage et
des politiques qui ferment les yeux sur
les 150 milliards il y en a une partie
qui est un peu détournée pour de
l'optimisation fiscale voire carrément
détournée
voici comment les aides d'État aux
entreprises
sont devenus un immense jeu de bluff
[Musique]
bonjour Amélie merci de nous recevoir
émilie a 25 ans elle est française tout
juste diplômée elle est ingénieur en
agroalimentaire
elle vit et travaille en Inde depuis 8
mois
là vous avez un chauffeur c'est le luxe
entreprise a décidé qui voulait me
donner un chauffeur pour venir au
travail et revenir allez on y va Émilie
effectue un vieux un volontariat
international en entreprise à Chennai en
Inde
[Musique]
tous les matins elle se rend dans une
usine du groupe Lactalis pour qui elle
travaille
comme tous les vieux elle est censée
aider l'entreprise à gagner des parts de
marché hors de France ici elle est
contre le qualité pour des yaourts
destinés au marché indien c'est
important parce qu'un jour vous pourriez
avoir des problèmes cette mission et son
premier emploi un emploi payé par l'état
français via une convention veilleuse
je gagne 2350 euros par mois
c'est pas du brut
c'est aussi
intéressant pour ça le veille c'est un
des 6000 dispositifs d'aide aux
entreprises qui existent en France
se produit c'est pour les végétariens
ce dispositif a été mis en place par
Jacques Chirac en l'an 2000 pour aider
les entreprises françaises à gagner des
parts de marché à l'international
le système est simple l'état engage des
jeunes de moins de 28 ans des vie qui
l'envoient en mission de 6 à 24 mois
dans des entreprises françaises à
l'étranger un système avantageux pour
l'employeur qui ne paye pas de charge
[Musique]
une aubaine c'est les producteurs
pour les entrepreneurs comme Jean-Marc
Desroches le patron d'Emilie qui dirige
la filiale indienne du groupe Lactalis
il y a un aspect financier extrêmement
intéressant pour nous
enfin c'est pratiquement moitié moins
cher donc on fait une économie
substantielle financière et surtout on a
la garantie que la personne est assurée
via le vieux tout le monde s'y retrouve
pour bénéficier du VO les règles sont
claires les Veilleux doivent
exclusivement aider au développement des
entreprises françaises à l'étranger en
aucun cas le veille ne doit être utilisé
pour gagner des parts de marché en
France ce qui équivaudrait à une
délocalisation financée par l'État
impensable
pourtant la Cour des comptes s'inquiète
dans son rapport annuel en 2011 elle met
en garde l'agence publique en charge des
voeux
ubif France il n'est pas exclu que des
entreprises utilisent les services du
bifrance dans le cadre d'un transfert
d'activité de la France vers un pays
tiers
d'après la Cour des comptes certaines
entreprises utiliseraient les vie pour
délocaliser leurs production nous avons
voulu vérifier
en Inde le plus gros consommateur de
veille a longtemps été une start-up
inconnue du grand public
car RDS
le métier de kRDS faire de la publicité
pour ses clients sur les réseaux sociaux
l'agence travaille avec de grandes
sociétés européennes comme Peugeot Air
France ou encore Danone elle a été
fondée en 2008 par quatre jeunes
diplômés
[Musique]
sur cette vidéo l'une des rares
interviews de l'un des fondateurs dans
ses bureaux à Paris
Thomas
à communiquer à se positionner sur
Facebook nous on les aide d'abord à
gagner les fans puis ensuite à animer
les fans et justement on va pouvoir les
animer en notamment leur proposant des
jeux des applications en quelque sorte
on a un peu contribué à ouvrir ce marché
du Facebook marketing en France
aujourd'hui kRDS c'est près de 150
collaborateurs une croissance Express un
véritable conte de fées numériques
[Musique]
atchennaï la filiale indienne de kerds
est situé au quatrième étage de ce
centre d'affaires
de nombreuses entreprises
internationales y ont élu domicile
voici les rares images disponibles des
locaux de guerre DS elles ont été
tournées en 2011 un grand plateau en
travaux pour accueillir une centaine de
personnes
[Musique]
alors kRDS utilise-t-elle bien ses
veilleurs pour trouver des clients à
l'international comme le prévoit le
dispositif
nous essayons d'entrer
[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle Jérôme cesquin nous
cherchons cette entreprise dont le siège
est ici il vous faut en laisser passer
ah il me faut une autorisation oui c'est
ça sans autorisation de kRDS nous ne
pouvons pas entrer
nous contactons donc l'un des patrons
Thomas Guenoux
oui bonjour on est à Chennai et on
aurait aimé vous rencontrer
vous n'êtes pas de chez naï d'accord
est-ce qu'il y a d'autres représentants
de
kRDS ADN
vous allez voir
il me répondra d'accord au revoir
Luc c'est le directeur local il a refusé
de nous recevoir
un ancien employé indien de kRDS à lui
accepté de nous rencontrer
critiquer son employeur en Inde et très
mal vu il nous a été très difficile de
trouver un témoin cet homme accepte de
nous parler anonymement
[Musique]
je développais des applications Facebook
je t'ai payé environ 500 euros par mois
et de quel pays était les clients
la France tous les clients étaient
français un maximum de français quelques
clients italiens mais la plupart étaient
français
et comment vous communiquez avec les
clients en français
nous on leur parlait pas ce sont les
vieux qui leur parlaient seuls les vies
pouvaient parler avec les clients
français c'était la règle
kRDS utilise bien ses Veilleux en Inde
pour travailler avec des clients
français leur mission serait donc
détournée si cela est vrai l'entreprise
ferait de la délocalisation avec des
subventions de l'État français
nous apprenons que les Français qui
travaillent pour kRDS sont logés par
l'entreprise dans ce quartier de bord de
mer
alors bonjour c'est ici que vive les
Français de kRDS
et combien de Français
selon lui ils doivent mentir aux clients
et cacher qu'ils sont basés en Inde une
instruction de la direction de kRDS
[Musique]
qui préfèrent pas non plus trop dire
qu'on en Inde qu'on les gens
à faire appel à une entreprise en France
début à la base mais bon je vous le dis
ça
un peu délocalisé quoi
on vous souhaite un bon weekend merci
beaucoup au revoir
nous avons rendez-vous avec trois
anciens veillus de kRDS 1
ils acceptent de nous raconter à visage
masqué la marche à suivre mise en place
par l'entreprise pour délocaliser des
règles auxquelles étaient soumis tous
les salariés et Veilleux de kRDS adjeney
premier point comment cacher qu'ils sont
en Inde
on était censés en France soit à Lyon
soit Paris c'est à dire que vous arrivez
au bureau vers 13h quand il est 9h en
France faisant nous on travaille en même
temps que nos clients et ça permet de ne
pas éveiller de soupçon la deuxième
façon c'est que on était tous équipés en
fait de téléphone avec des numéros
français c'est la magie de Skype le
client appelle sur un 01 mais vous êtes
à l'autre bout du monde un d'entre eux
nous montre un email avec les consignes
de la direction de kerds pour les vie en
Inde d'échanger quelques mots au pied
levés sur Lyon au cas où quelques infos
que vous voyez sur Street View aggravé
dans votre cerveau au rez-de-chaussée un
magasin fossiles marocainerie notre
bureau est en face du McDo pour la météo
dites que ça va et Google élite il y a
eu quelques boulettes et une anecdote
c'était ah oui aujourd'hui il fait super
beau à Paris et là le chef de projet a
dû dire ah ben nous on est en pleine
mousse
ces anciens Veilleux dénoncent une autre
tromperie cette fois-ci vis-à-vis des
autorités indiennes à l'époque où il
travaillait pour kRDS l'Inde
n'autorisait que 50 veille sur son
territoire pour contourner ce quota kRDS
leur fait signer un second contrat de
travail indien
un contrat
[Musique]
un Veilleux caché d'obtenir un visa de
travail
pour preuve cet email dans lequel la
responsable des ressources humaines
confirme la manipulation noire sur blanc
la Veilleux qu'il l'a reçu nous le lit
cependant ce n'est que de la poudre aux
yeux pour les autorités indiennes en
réalité tu viens à nous rejoindre pour
effectuer un vieux 24 mois
pour que la tromperie soit parfaite
kRDS leur verset même un salaire indien
de l'argent versé sur un compte qu'il
fallait rendre tous les mois en liquide
à l'entreprise
et que je reversais réellement de la
main à la main à la société
à l'époque où ces jeunes Veilleux
effectuaient leur mission pour kRDS en
Inde le directeur de la filiale était
Brice Leconte aujourd'hui il a quitté
l'entreprise en déplacement à l'étranger
il accepte de répondre à nos questions
en visioconférence
bonjour
premier point la délocalisation cachée
il admet que certains veillaient ont
bien travaillé en Inde pour des clients
français
es en Inde pour la production
et les veilleurs ont utilisé
majoritairement majoritairement pour
faire de la production mais est-ce que
c'était des Veilleux qui étaient
utilisés pour développer des produits
pour la France
en 2011 effectivement c'est
majoritairement français
beaucoup d'anciennes vieux de l'année
2013 et pour eux tous les clients
étaient français Danone Air France
Canal+
oui leurs clients
c'est les quatre cinq
vélos
second point les faux contrats fait pour
tromper les autorités indiennes des
contrats vont vous en souvenez qualifiés
de poudre aux yeux par la responsable
des ressources humaines de kRDS Brice
Leconte commence par réfuter
mais moi j'en ai des emails ou en leur
explique au moment de les signer que
c'est de la poudre aux yeux c'est le
terme exact employé
dernier point les salaires indiens que
les veille devaient rendre en liquide à
l'entreprise
rendre un salaire en cash que vous avez
touché de votre employeur déclaré ça
c'est illégal
d'exiger un remboursement on est
d'accord on est d'accord voilà
selon lui cet argent finissait dans une
cagnotte au bénéfice de tous les
salariés
président investissez dans une cagnotte
commune et aller chercher le week-end
des
lits des
télés
on leur demandait pas d'aller acheter
des meubles ou je ne sais quoi on leur
demandait de rendre de l'argent en cash
pour moi
ça va il y a du bricolage
d'après lui kRDS aurait cessé cette
pratique en 2013
[Musique]
nous avons contacté à plusieurs reprises
les dirigeants actuels de kerds pour
savoir ce qu'il en est aujourd'hui
pour seule réponse un email dans lequel
il conteste les accusations nous n'ayons
fermement les allégations que vous
présentez comme des fêtes troublant
l'agence publique en charge des vies
s'appelle
ubi France c'est elle qui les place dans
les entreprises et les rémunèrent
que savaient tubif France des pratiques
contestables de kRDS
choqué par les abus de l'entreprise
certains veillaient ont alerté ubis
France en 2013
une réunion est alors organisée à
Chennai avec un des représentants de
l'Agence publique en Inde
une rencontre qu'un vieux a enregistré
nous nous sommes procurés ce document
exceptionnel
sur cet enregistrement sonore c'est le
représentant Dubi France que l'on entend
[Musique]
il semble informer que l'entreprise fait
de la délocalisation cachée
pire il ferme les yeux sur le système
mis en place par kRDS
[Musique]
retour à Paris
nous avons pris rendez-vous avec le
directeur général délégué actuel du
bifrance renommée aujourd'hui business
France
travaillait déjà pour l'agence publique
à l'époque des faits
OK
visiblement kRDS a délocalisé sa
production française pour ses clients
français en Inde est-ce que c'est ça
l'esprit du vieux non clairement c'est
pas l'esprit du vieux c'est un point que
nous allons faire en fait avec
l'entreprise un recadrage s'il y a
besoin et si il faut si certaines
missions sont pas dans les clous on les
refera je vais vous faire écouter
quelque chose
nous lui faisons écouter
l'enregistrement de la réunion entre des
Veilleux de kRDS et le représentant
business France en Inde
on a l'impression que kRDS et business
France c'est peut-être pas le cas mais
c'est l'impression que ça donne son main
dans la main pour exploiter des jeunes
pour une délocalisation quand il y a un
problème comme celui-là pourquoi les
signaux ne sont pas entendus et passer
de 14 vieux à l'époque à 4 Veilleux donc
vous pouvez pas dire qu'on n'a pas
entendu les signaux
vous pouvez pas dire ça vous prenez une
situation là qui n'a plus rien à voir en
2015 mais qu'en 2013 quand je vous ai
parlé délocalisation vous m'avez dit que
vous étiez surpris là maintenant vous me
dites on l'a réglé donc en fait vous
avez été informé que cette entreprise
pratiquait la délocalisation en se
servant des vies pour cela on a corrigé
un certain nombre de fake qui nous
savaient terminé et donc on continuera à
le faire on attend certainement encore
plus encore plus vigilant si besoin
d'accord bon ben je vous remercie
kRDS est-il un cas isolé difficile de le
savoir
le dispositif rencontre un grand succès
le nombre de vieux a doublé en disant
le deuxième dispositif d'aide aux
entreprises pointées pour ses dérives
c'est le CIR le crédit impôt recherche
un vieux dispositif que Nicolas Sarkozy
décide de booster en 2008 pour inciter
les entreprises à investir dans la
recherche et créer de l'emploi la France
dispose maintenant du dispositif fiscal
le plus attractif au monde en termes de
recherche avec le Crédit Impôt Recherche
à 30%. quand on vient de dire ça coûte
cher non ça coûte pas cher ça marche
là aussi le système est simple toute
entreprise qui finance de la recherche
et développement jusqu'à un plafond de
100 millions d'euros peut bénéficier
d'une déduction d'impôts équivalent à
30% de ses investissements
le crédit d'impôt recherche coûte
presque 6 milliards d'euros par an à
l'état plus de 15000 entreprises en
bénéficient
[Musique]
bonjour
votre situation fiscale du coup avec
plaisir il y a pas beaucoup de voix de
qui acceptent de parler de leurs
chiffres comme ça j'imagine mais sa
spécialité c'est la gestion de méga
donnés les Big Data sur Internet
depuis 2014 Adrien perçoit 100.000 euros
de crédit impôt recherche
un chèque qui lui a permis de
relocaliser en France des emplois de
chercheurs employés jusqu'ici au Vietnam
les chats seraient pas équilibré que mes
recettes si j'avais pas le crédit
d'impôt recherche je perdrai de l'argent
on aurait peut-être une ou deux
personnes ici et puis le et puis le gros
du gros des troupes au Vietnam
c'est l'entreprise qui calcule elle-même
le crédit impôt recherche auquel elle a
droit pour cela elle doit comptabiliser
le temps passé par chacun de ses
employés sur les projets de recherche
dans les calculs certains ont trouvé des
astuces pour maximiser leur subventions
Arnaud Lambert a dirigé un cabinet de
conseil pour le financement de startup
un de ces cabinets qui aide les
entreprises à calculer leur crédit impôt
recherche il nous révèle comment
certaines d'entre elles le font gonfler
en jouant sur le temps de travail des
chercheurs là je vais vous montrer
comment en quelques clics on va réussir
à optimiser notre cire optimiser au
tricher à tricher d'accord par exemple
du crédit pour recherche de 74000 euros
qui ne me satisfait pas en l'état j'ai
besoin 240 ou 150000 euros pour
équilibrer mes comptes globalement j'ai
besoin du double donc je vais lui mettre
ici un taux de R&D de 28%
le chef d'entreprise va augmenter le
temps de travail des chercheurs sur la
R&D la recherche est développement qui
bénéficie du crédit d'impôt
lui on va le mettre peut-être à 30%
c'est facile à justifier on peut dire
qu'il a passé un tiers de son temps sur
le sur la R&D et puis on progresse comme
ça surtout les sur tous les profils et
on s'aperçoit que ça monte assez vite
très vite le cier double et cerise sur
le gâteau l'État n'a aucun moyen de
contrôle on arrive à 151 584 euros de
CIA donc je l'ai doublé en changeant 10
cases de mon fichier Excel et c'est un
contrôlable contrôleur il pourra pas me
contredire du tout vous êtes persuadé
que c'est ce qui se fait dans la plupart
des gens je suis persuadé que c'est ce
qui se fait peut-être pas dans la
plupart des boîtes mais dans un nombre
important de boîtes et c'est aujourd'hui
ce qui contribue à la croissance de
l'ardoise globale que l'on paye au
niveau du sien au niveau national
des risques de dérive dénoncer des 2013
par la Cour des comptes des stratégies
d'optimisation visant à maximiser
l'avantage fiscal accordé au titre du
CIR peuvent se développer dans la durée
autre problème le cier n'est pas le
booster d'emplois promis à l'Institut de
physique du globe nous avons rendez-vous
avec François Métivier il fait partie de
science en marche un collectif
d'universitaires qui milite contre les
dérives du crédit impôt recherche dans
une étude il démontre que beaucoup de
grands groupes n'utiliseraient pas le
CIA pour embaucher mais pour améliorer
leur rentabilité
qu'est-ce qu'on voit mais on voit pour
les entreprises de moins de salariés ça
a l'air de marcher pour les entreprises
de plus de 500 salariés patatras c'est
l'inverse la courte théorique elle est
là et les vrais dépenses de recherche
sont largement en dessous ça veut dire
quoi mais ça veut dire qu'en fait les
entreprises ont touché du cier et
qu'elle n'en ont réinvesti qu'une partie
et donc il y a toute une partie
d'essayer qui est parti ailleurs donc
pour optimiser les marges baisser les
coûts généraux diminuer les impôts
j'aurais tendance à dire mais peut-être
pas ça un crédit d'impôt recherche c'est
pas parce que vous calculez sur les
dépenses de recherche que ça fait de la
recherche
pour décrocher un maximum de crédit
impôt recherche certaines grandes
entreprises ont trouvé des astuces
c'est le cas de Renault
rappelez-vous la règle
toute entreprise qui finance de la
recherche peut bénéficier d'une
déduction d'impôts équivalent à 30% de
leurs investissements
mais l’état a prévu une limite au-dessus
de 100 millions
la déduction d'impôts tombe à 5%
, pour contourner ce plafond Renault a
créé des plus petites filiales qui
investissent chacune moins de 100
millions ainsi Renaud touche toujours
30% du
cirque totale investie
[Musique]
un tour de passe-passe qui en 2014 a
rapporté à Renault
144 millions d'euros
[Musique]
nous avons mis la main sur un document
interne qui confirme ce schéma fiscal
les retranscriptions d'un comité
d'entreprise de 2009 la direction évoque
deux filiales créées pour décrocher du
crédit pour recherche il n'y a pas de
personnel c'est un réceptacle comptable
qui a entre autres pour objectif de
pouvoir profiter des nouvelles
dispositions législatives
le représentant de la Direction
s'appelle Bernard Olivier directeur des
ingénieurs pour la France
il ajoute au sujet d'une troisième
filiale
cette société n'a pas de business elle
n'a pas de clients c'est une société qui
fait transiter des sommes qui permet de
les regrouper et de justifier un certain
nombre de choses vis-à-vis du CIM
nous nous rendons aux technocentre de
Renault à Guyancourt
nous y retrouvons un syndicaliste
présent lors de ce ce bonjour Jérôme
cesquin de Spécial Investigation Marc
swang confirme l'intégralité des
retranscriptions
la direction est créée des filiales pour
essayer de récupérer un peu plus
d'argent du crédit pour recherche
d'ailleurs c'est écrit dans le texte
effectivement c'est des coquilles vides
quoi
des coquilles vides pour toucher plus de
séismes
lors de ce un syndicat avait interpellé
la direction
CGT dit c'est une pompe à fric d'une
certaine façon donc Monsieur Bernard
Olivier dit d'abord il n'y a rien de
déshonorant d'être une pompe à fric il
est tout à fait honorable de que Renaud
applique la loi c'est un jeu de dupe et
qui se fait au détriment malheureusement
des salariés et des finances publiques
nous avons souhaité rencontrer Bernard
Olivier depuis il est devenu le PDG
d'une filiale prestigieuse de Renault
Alpine
pour fêter les 50 ans de cette marque
mythique un grand événement est organisé
à Dieppe
[Musique]
nous nous invitons à la fête pour savoir
si Bernard Olivier assume toujours les
coquilles vides de Renaud
[Musique]
d'entreprise monsieur le Président qui
représente nous qui dit d'abord il n'y a
rien de déshonorant d'être une pompe
Afrique il est tout à fait noble que
Renault applique la loi je redis que ces
filiales ne sont pas des filiales de
business donc en gros c'est une filiale
vide
le président dans ce document c'est vous
si je me trompe pas non c'est pas moi je
crois que c'est pas moi c'est pas vrai
parce que ça c'est Renault oui mais
c'est 2009 membres de direction
bolivier c'est vous directeur des
établissements d'améliori France
le groupe Renault n'a jamais fait de
choses illégales sur ce sujet on est
très vigilant finalement face aux
retranscription du comité d'entreprise
Bernard Olivier reconnaît ses propos des
filiales ont donc bien été créés pour
gonfler le crédit impôt recherche du
groupe Renault
ok merci beaucoup Monsieur Olivier je
vous remercie au revoir
en mars dernier le Sénat lance une
commission d'enquête sur le crédit impôt
recherche
Renault et convoqué devant la commission
pour répondre à ses accusations
Dominique Thorman le directeur financier
de Renault ni en bloc la réalité du
groupe Renault dans son emploi du crédit
d'impôt recherche c'est l'absence de
détournement de l'objet du cire il a
décidément pas d'effet d'aubaine chez
Renault pour ce qui est de la création
récente de Renault Dream et idve ce sont
des sociétés qui ne sont pas du tout
fictives
un discours qui convainc les sénateurs
j'ai été rassuré à la fois par les
réponses qui nous ont été apportées et
puis par l'approche que fait
l'entreprise Renault de la recherche par
son implantation en France de précision
Renault ne sera pas inquiété aucun
sénateur ne sait référer ou
retranscription du comité d'entreprise
nous allons rencontrer la rapporteur de
la commission Brigitte Gontier Morin
dans les salons dorés du Sénat
bonjour bonjour monsieur je suis ravi de
vous rencontrer nous voulons savoir
pourquoi les sénateurs n'ont pas produit
devant Renault le document
c'est marqué noir sur blanc qu'ils ont
créé cette filiale
si vous voulez on peut le regarder
ensemble regarder cette société n'a pas
de business elle n'a pas de clients
c'est une société qui fait transiter des
sommes qui permet de les regrouper et de
justifier un certain nombre de choses
vis-à-vis du CRF
il n'y a aucun salarié il n'y aura
personne oui mais pourquoi vous avez pas
poussé jusque là avec pourquoi c'est
toute la difficulté de montrer le
dispositif je crois que ce dispositif
est devenu quelque chose de tabou
l'amorce une pompe à fric je reprends le
terme qui n'est pas contrôlé qui n'est
pas maîtrisé et on demande rien à
personne
ces questions que les sénateurs ont
oublié de poser nous décidons de nous en
charger
nous contactons la direction de Renault
qui ne nous répondra jamais alors nous
partons à Francfort en Allemagne pour le
Salon de l'automobile
en arrivant le hasard fait bien les
choses nous tombons sur Dominique
Thorman le directeur financier de
Renault
[Musique]
celui qui a été auditionné par le Sénat
public
vous avez vous avez communiqué devant le
Sénat la commission d'enquête sur le
crédit impôt recherche vraiment j'ai pas
plus à la question est-ce que c'est
filiale notamment deux d'entre elles ont
été créées pour permettre de toucher
plus de crédit d'impôt recherche parce
que la loi est utilisée ce que j'ai dit
mon texte il est public donc j'ai rien
de plus à ajouter par rapport à ce que
j'ai dit au Sénat et moi j'ai un
document qui dit le contraire ce sont
des propos qui ont été confirmés par
Monsieur Bernard Olivier que j'ai
interviewé regardez regardez le document
qui est Bernard Olivier mais le PDG
deltine quand même vous connaissez
Bernard Olivier le PDG Delphine
Jérôme cesquin de la chaîne Canal+ pour
le magazine Spécial Investigation il n'y
a rien de déshonorant d'être une pompe à
fric l'objet de ces filiales est
absolument pas d'accueillir du personnel
il est de permettre de récupérer du cuir
du crédit à vos recherches
donc il y a une contradiction entre ce
que vous avez dit devant le Sénat et
entre ce qu'on lit dans ce document je
crois que vous savez que j'étais
témoigné sincèrement j'ai rien d'autre à
dire
il dérange ce document je crois
Carlos Ghosn le PDG de Renault s'est
déplacé pour l'occasion nous tentons
notre chance
[Applaudissements]
fait l'objet d'une polémique médiatique
au sujet du crédit pour recherche on
vous a pas entendu vous exprimer sur le
sujet qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire est-ce que Renault respecte la loi
certainement ça je peux vous le dire
maintenant je le patron d'une va pas
commenter sur tout ce qui arrive autour
d'un constructeur automobile par contre
la seule chose que je peux que je peux
garantir c'est que Renault respecte
depuis l'agence les lois de tous les
pays dans lesquels il se trouve
particulièrement son pays d'origine donc
les filiales qui ont été créés
le responsable presse de Renault nous
prend à part je suis Bruno Moreau
j'aimerais bien j'ai un certain nombre
d'informations que j'aimerais vérifier
et qu'on comprenne et qu'on décrypte en
fait comment ce montage financier a été
mis en place les différentes filiales
vous entendez par montage financier
en 2009 elles ont été créées on est
d'accord elles ont été créées en 2000
moi je vous dis juste ça sert à quoi je
vous dis juste
je vous dis juste
je suis transparent dans mon mail vous
pouvez lui demander je vous je vous ai
dit l'objet de mon enquête dans mon ex
qui touche à la à la fiscalité ça nous
regarde pas le grand public 144 millions
c'est de l'argent public donc ça ça nous
regarde peut-être que si vous ne faisiez
pas ça on ne pouvait pas tenir les 3000
postes ingénieurs qu'on a au technicien
en fait etc et que du coup on sera
obligé de transférer nous paraît donc
dans d'autres secteurs selon lui sans
cet argent Renaud serait donc contraint
de délocaliser
l'état connaît-il les astuces de Renault
pour augmenter son CIR
nous sommes partis à la rencontre du
secrétaire d'État à la recherche Thierry
Mandon
ce jour-là au Sénat Thierry Mandon est
convié à un débat sur le crédit impôt
recherche les filiales de Renault sont
évoqués nous l'attendons à la sortie de
l'hémicycle et tentons d'obtenir des
explications
[Musique]
monsieur Mandon j'ai vraiment une
question à vous poser qui est importante
vous avez entendu pendant les les débats
le cas Renault est revenu
nous on a eu accès au fameux comités
d'entreprise ou il est clairement écrit
que Renault a créé en 2009 des filiales
pour optimiser son crédit pour recherche
est-ce que vous trouvez ça normal et
pourquoi pourquoi
Thierry Mandon ne donnera jamais suite à
notre demande d'interview
[Musique]
mais c'est un sénateur républicain qui
va nous révéler le potau rose Francis
Delattre et vice-président de la
commission des finances c'est lui qui
dirigeait la commission d'enquête sur le
crédit impôt recherche
il admet que Renault bénéficie d'un
régime de faveur et trouve cela
parfaitement normal une entreprise qui
crée des filiales spécifiquement pour
obtenir plus de crédit d'impôts de
recherche est-ce que c'est normal le
problème ils ont pas créé pour avoir
plus de recherche j'ai un document oui
discret clairement on a créé ces
filiales pour ça sur la document qui a 6
ans avec un syndicalisme je sais pas qui
moi je crois monsieur gosse qui préside
la boîte et qui est le responsable et au
service
parfaitement au courant du montage merci
à valider ce schéma fiscal et puis je
comprends qu'il est validé
mais pourquoi c'est pas transparent
pourquoi c'est pas public
deux entreprises automobiles franchement
même s'il a un peu de faveur je trouve
pas ça scandaleux comme parlementaire
selon ce sénateur les coquilles vides de
Renault auraient été validés par Bercy
un régime de faveur en dépit des limites
fixées par la loi
en 7 ans le coup du crédit impôt
recherche a été multiplié par 3 et
atteint presque 6 milliards d'euros
les grands groupes comme Renault ils
sont sans doute pour beaucoup
[Musique]
dernière carte à abattre sur notre tapis
vert le cice
le crédit d'impôt compétitivité emploi
l'une des mesures phares du quinquennat
de François Hollande
le 13 novembre 2012 François Hollande
nouvellement élu fait une proposition
aux entreprises
une proposition en or
le Premier ministre a annoncé un crédit
d'impôt pour la compétitivité et pour
l'emploi d'un montant de 20 milliards
d'euros dont 10 des 2013 ce n'est pas un
cadeau
comme je l'entends que l'État fait c'est
un pacte de confiance pour que
l'investissement soit préféré à la
distribution de dividendes pour que
l'emploi soit réalisé en France plutôt
qu'ailleurs et pour que la richesse crée
puisse être mieux répartis le cice est
né son principe est simple pour tout
salaire inférieur à 3600 euros brut
l'état rembourse à l'entreprise 6% du
salaire charge incluse selon le
gouvernement ce dispositif est censé
créer 500 000 emplois
l'État est financièrement en échange le
patron embauche ce devait être la règle
pour le cice
mais un homme s'est battu pour que cela
ne soit pas le cas
cet homme c'est Pierre Gattaz le
président du Medef
pour lui les patrons doivent utiliser à
leur guise l'argent du cice sans
obligation d'embaucher et il a obtenu
gain de cause aucune contrepartie des
patrons en échange des milliardaires de
l'État
mais pour rassurer Gattaz a fait une
promesse les patrons feront tout pour
embaucher même au-delà des 500 000
emplois promis par le gouvernement
voyez un million d'emplois comme un
objectif c'est un objectif que nous
voulons prendre mais c'est comme un
objectif d'entreprise c'est un projet et
bien nous visons ce projet là mais c'est
pas un engagement fermé définitif
à la flèche dans la Sarthe où il frite
Bodart dirige depuis 8 ans MTF une PME
de tuyauterie industriel
une entreprise qui se porte très bien et
qui fait sa fierté
[Musique]
combien vous faites de chiffre
d'affaires pour l'année dernière on a
fait un million d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires
c'était une société que moi j'ai créé il
y a 8 ans de zéro pour un sentiment
poche
juste avec un rêve c'était de créer des
emplois voilà tout simplement
en février dernier il a reçu son premier
crédit d'impôt compétitivité emploi le
cice
un coup de pouce pour embaucher on a
embauché Guy ici on a embauché Anthony
là-bas on a on a embauché Rudy qui se
trouve derrière on a embauché Philippe
qui se trouve là-bas qui est le
responsable de chantier et Maryline qui
est à la comptabilité sans l'argent du
cice vous ne les auriez pas embauché
vite il y avait besoin de monde c'était
bienvenu
[Applaudissements]
vous nous montrez combien vous allez
toucher de cice
[Applaudissements]
ça ressemble à
aujourd'hui c'est le crédit d'impôt pour
la conductivité et l'emploi
15432 euros c'est une belle somme c'est
important c'est comme ça qu'on avance
toutes les entreprises ne jouent pas le
jeu aussi honnêtement que Wilfried
une experte la démontré elle nous a
donné rendez-vous chez elle en Savoie
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour
elle a longtemps travaillé pour les
syndicats
en fait je vous détricotez les contes
des entreprises j'essaye de trouver dans
chaque entreprise ces petites
manipulations pour faire disparaître aux
yeux des salariés des véritables
résultats de l'entreprise
accord Carrefour Hermès ou encore Ikea
elle les a tous passé au crible elle
s'est aussi penchée sur radial
l'entreprise de Pierre Gattaz le
président du Medef qui a touché un
million 400.000 euros de cice en 2014 et
surprise en moyenne sur l’année l'homme
qui promettait un million d'emplois n'en
a pas créé un seul dans sa propre
entreprise
sont passés de
1107 à 1066 il y a une diminution en
moyenne sur l'année des effectifs
salariés chez radial en France
donc même les 13 qu'il a recruté si on
fait la moyenne sur l'année il diminue
il y a eu plus de départ que d'embauche
des emplois salariés supprimés compensés
par des emplois intérimaires mais alors
où est donc parti l'argent du cice chez
radial là aussi Arlette pense avoir
trouvé la réponse dans les documents
officiels de l'entreprise
dans la rémunération des actionnaires
les dividendes
actionnaires chez radial composé pour
plus de 90% par la famille Gattaz
[Musique]
donc on voit apparaître le montant du
cice d'un million 460000 1460 euros et
entre 2013 et 2014 les dividendes sont
passées de 27 à 4 millions 6 et là ça
largement absorbé le cice
il va dans les dividendes
pas de salariés supplémentaires des
dividendes qui augmentent radial
l'entreprise de Pierre gataz aurait-elle
utilisé le cice pour accroître ses
marges
nous avons récupéré un document
confidentiel qui confirme ces infos les
retranscriptions d'un comité
d'entreprise de 2015
la direction indique que le cice a été
utilisé pour sauvegarder ses marges
pas d'embauche des marges sauvegardées
et donc mécaniquement des actionnaires
mieux rémunérés
une opération légale du patron de radial
pierre Gattaz mais très loin des
objectifs de création d'emploi affichés
par le président du Medef pierre Gattaz
nous sommes allés à sa rencontre au
siège du Medef dans le 7e arrondissement
de Paris la question de la création
d'emploi dans ce pays et la question
cruciale avec la sécurité de évidemment
ce jour-là l'homme qui voulait créer un
million d'emplois donne même dans la
surenchère
[Musique]
si nous voulons revenir au plein emploi
c'est-à-dire en dessous de 6% de chômage
il faut créer non pas un million
d'emplois mais 2 millions d'emplois je
suis prêt à répondre à toutes vos
questions bonjour Concernant l'objectif
de pleine emploi que vous avez évoqué
est-ce que vous comprenez que les
Français doutent des intentions du Medef
alors que l'État français n'a jamais
fait un aussi grand effort financé pour
les entreprises par ailleurs dans votre
entreprise vous avez loué le cice à la
sauvegarde des marges est-ce que vous ne
pensez pas que le président du Medef a
un devoir d'exemplarité aurait pu aussi
créer quelques emplois dans son
entreprise
je peux vous en parler un petit peu je
connais bien le dossier d'abord il faut
savoir si vous voulez que
depuis une vingtaine d'années j'ai créé
j'ai créé 600 emplois en France et 1500
emplois en dehors de la France
si vous voulez ça nous a permis de
continuer d'innover très fortement
puisque nous consacrons
cette à 8% par an du chiffre d'affaires
et nous investissons en équipement entre
3 et 5% par an et voilà c'est c'est pas
parti en dividende c'est rentrer c'est
rester dans la boîte et c'est du concret
alors après si vous voulez
l'emploi ça ne se décrète pas vous savez
le problème de l'emploi c'est qu'on
croit tous que on appuie sur un bouton
on n'appuie pas sur deux boutons le cice
a déjà coûté 30 milliards d'euros et
selon l'Insee il n'a permis la création
que de 140 000 emplois soit 200 000
euros par emploi c'est très loin des 500
000 promis par le gouvernement et du
million annoncé par Pierre Gattaz
le jeu en vaut-il la chandelle pas du
tout pour l'ancien ministre de
l'économie et des finances l'ultra
libéral à la Madeleine
vous avez le marché économique que vous
avez le marché politique
avec des groupes de pression et les
groupes de pression qui font une
pression d'autant plus forte qui peuvent
tirer un gros avantage moralité tout
prétexte est bon pour essayer de
récupérer un peu quelqu'un genre de la
part du gouvernement et à l'arrivée vous
avez même le patron qui tient au statut
quo quand on avait voulu réformer le
cice parce que
au fond des gens qui s'habituent à la
subvention il y a des gens qui
bénéficient d'une position de rente et
puis personne n'a envie de bouger c'est
comme un jeu de poker un peu je sais pas
où chacun
objectivement tous ces bricolages
on arrive au bout
on résume une entreprise qui utilise les
vieux pour délocaliser
une autre qui crée des filiales pour
gonfler son crédit impôt recherche
et enfin le patron des patrons qui a
loue un dispositif censé favoriser
l'emploi à ces marges décidément au jeu
des aides aux entreprises les patrons
sont les rois du bluff et l'État qui n'a
jamais été aussi généreux envers les
entreprises semble ne pas y voir grand
chose
jusqu'à présent Michel Sapin n'a pas
répondu à nos sollicitations profite du
fait qu'aujourd'hui il fait une
conférence de presse à Bercy pour aller
lui poser quelques questions
ce jour-là Michel Sapin ministre des
Finances et son collègue Emmanuel Macron
sont venus présenter un rapport de
l'Observatoire du financement des
entreprises
monsieur sapin ce que je peux vous poser
une petite question on fait une enquête
pour Canal+ un documentaire d'une heure
sur les aides et subventions entreprises
on s'est intéressé à plusieurs
dispositifs cice hier même un petit
dispositif le volontariat international
c'est un crédit d'impôts
des 150 milliards que l'État accorde aux
entreprises on a relevé plein de
dysfonctionnements on aimerait avoir
votre point de vue pour essayer de
comprendre pourquoi il y a si peu de
surveillance sur l'argent qui est donné
aux entreprises on a l'impression que
sur les 150 milliards il y en a une
partie qui est un peu détournée pour de
l'optimisation fiscale voire carrément
détournée
et on aimerait pouvoir vous interroger
précisément sur ces points j'aimerais
prendre un rendez-vous avec vous pour
vous solliciter
vous me promettez c'est possible
merci beaucoup au revoir
l'interview promise n'aura jamais lieu
visiblement les trois dispositifs qui
représentent chaque année plus de 20
milliards d'euros d'argent public ne
méritent pas d'explication du
gouvernement
[Musique]
au terme de notre enquête on a le
désagréable sentiment que les
entreprises jouent avec l'argent public
que l'État les laisse faire et qu'au
final ce sont toujours les contribuables
qui se font bluffer